philippine right now a utv crash on
christmas eve leaves one man in custody
26 year old yasmani flamen is facing
reckless driving charges but tonight his
sister the victim in this incident says
her brother doesn't deserve the blame
madison kimbrough is at umc with her
story
isabella was in the passenger seat when
the wreck occurred on friday and now
she's here at umc where she had to have
her right arm amputated after the utv
crashed rolled onto its side and flipped
upwards it being less than two days
since the crash isabella wants people to
know that the crash was an accident and
that her brother 26 year old yasmani
flemen is not to blame flemen is the one
who lost control of the vehicle that
christmas eve night isabella says she
and the rest of the family are upset
with how nlvpd handled the situation and
don't want her brother labeled as a
criminal after being arrested and
charged for reckless driving the first
voice i heard was my brother's he said
sister are you okay it was unjustified
there was no reason for him to go to
jail we had just pulled into the parking
lot he was going at 26. he had he wasn't
drinking that night he wasn't he wasn't
on anything he was completely sober
other than isabella and her brother two
other people were in the u-t-v one being
isabella's boyfriend who suffered
non-life-threatening injuries we plan on
talking to him later tonight reporting
from umc madison kimbrough live local
now